scale let me see my boy volodar
he's 14 years old 2500 putting up a
fight here against artemia
the very experienced 23 year old
he's a he's a part of our team if not
typical our tv of game no suffering out
of the opening but then you know he
hangs in there
it's very resourceful okay i have to
update again
and he loves the g pawn um that looks
bad
because now this pawn and the king is
very safe there
you you can never exchange queens
and queen e5 is coming i'm afraid he has
to get checked
to take but this is probably not nice
yes
he did he did
he did and he's running with the the
king
where the world is the wrong square so
you can
hope for some miracle but
now king comes
how do you do it do you go h4 or do you
leave it there maybe i go h4
sweet bishop g2 if i can yeah h4 king f4
you can supply where
bishop d7 then bring the king he's
thinking it's a big decision
just to know if you will go bishop e8
king v8 king c7 and so on
or push it he did push it please for
king f4 h3 will come off
we should decide keeping the king
guessing yeah now
the bishop can go to c8 if needed to
cover everything and you start the
kickstarter
played king b8 yeah
that is going to be tough for your boy
yeah you go chasing here here
even that oh it's not so clear
oh is it i'm not sure okay let's see it
should just be lost
yeah you mentioned there's the
so-called wrong bishop so if you went b6
b takes a5 you would probably not win
with the remaining a pawn
but you don't have to you can't cover
your b-pawn like this
bishop f3 bishop c8 now he wants to
bring the king obviously
i would have been very tempted by bishop
c6 but okay
he seems to know what he's doing bishop
only two
is a tremendous tactic technician
tactician as well
but look b5 might come
i'm not sure it was the right way to to
post it actually but okay
could be wrong obviously because let's
say this
already i mean i'm saving it saving the
day now
uh of course that was i was helping
myself
i was helping my case by playing bad
moves but
there is we see some scenario where
it's a doll yeah how does black do this
maybe you start with
no it's gotta say bishop d7 but then we
show e4 again it's hard to make progress
i think you should you should
come as a bishop here puts upon his
sweet bishop on g2 and come with the
king
something like that
and he did all over f5
shouldn't this be a draw yeah let's just
sing seven b5 wow that's amazing
was completely wrong
look at murshid he knows he's surviving
a little little peak there at artemia
saying 21 year old you would have won
this
should d7 we have a6
wow tactics a6
nice a6 so strong
okay i
it took bishop a6 and
that's simply a do total
chilling having a look at that game
hands behind us back and
what what are the remaining games